près de quatre mois ont passé mais la
douleur de ces villageois est intacte
ensemble ils rendent hommage à leurs
proches ou voisins victime de l'un des
nombreux massacres commis pendant la
guerre aux tigres et selon la paroisse
locale cent soixante quatre civils ont
été tués à dingo la fin novembre dernier
le jour d'une grande fête orthodoxe des
hommes armés en uniforme parlant une
langue érythréenne sont arrivés en
silence ils ont ensuite extirper les
hommes et les garçons pour les emmener
en contrebas d'une colline où ils les
ont abattus
les survivants sont encore traumatisés
j'aurais préféré mourir que de vivre
pour voir cela mais je ne peux pas me
suicider ce genre de crime est fait pour
nous exterminer pour nous humilier pour
nous faire tomber sous leur coupe
aucun élément n'a encore permis
d'identifier les auteurs de ce massacre
mais les témoignages font penser à des
troupes érythréennes qui pourrait avoir
appuyé l'armée éthiopienne malgré les
dénégations officielles d'asmara après
un mois de violents affrontements contre
le front de libération du peuple du
tigré le premier ministre éthiopien
habib ahmed avait proclamé la fin de
l'opération militaire
les autorités locales en fuite ont de
leur côté promis de poursuivre la lutte
si aucun bilan officiel n'est disponible
les combats auraient fait des milliers
de morts selon des ong
ils ont aussi provoqué un afflux de
réfugiés vers le soudan voisin
face à ce désastre humanitaire l'onu a
passé plusieurs accords avec les
autorités éthiopiennes garantissant un
accès total à leur territoire en
engagement qui n'est pas pleinement
respectée par les autorités d'addis
abeba
des centaines de milliers de personnes
touchées par les combats n'ont pas pu
être approchés notamment dans les zones
rurales du tigre et malgré les nombreux
défis
les humanitaires présents sur le terrain
s'emploient à accroître l'aide avec
quelques progrès réalisés notamment ce
qui concerne l'aide alimentaire dans les
principales villes
la guerre aux tigres et sera au coeur
des discussions du conseil de sécurité
ce jeudi il s'était déjà réuni à ce
sujet le 2 février les pays africains
représentés avaient refusé l'idée
déclaration commune pour réclamer aux
autorités d'addis abeba un meilleur
accès humanitaire